syrians who have experienced the horrors
of War firsthand eagerly await news from
Turkey
many here have family members across the
border and want to know how this
election will affect them
[Music]
I have many relatives living in turkey
and working to support their families
here the calls we're hearing about
deporting syrians who are living there
would have very bad consequences
especially on a humanitarian scale
[Music]
the display series have been supported
by humanitarian Aid coming through the
northern Turkish border
but they fear that it might disappear
for good
no matter who wins we hope that turkey's
approach will not follow the approach of
deporting syrians which will have dire
future consequences on the humanitarian
sector here as more than 1.8 million
people are already living in refugee
camps
turkey has elections could also alter
the Region's political landscape
president
erdogan's government has sent troops to
Northern Syria and has been coordinating
with this year in opposition for years
and political activists believe the
policies of whoever wins will shape the
future dynamics of the entire region
the Turkish elections have great
significance for the Syrian issue these
elections have an effect on syrians
especially in the north and on syrians
presently in Turkey a as for us as a
political body in idlib of course we
believe that these elections are decided
by the Turkish people
as Northern Syria continues to deal with
their devastating effects of its 12-year
War
many here wonder what the Turkish
elections will mean for them
in Syria's bustling markets there is a
semblance of normalcy as people go about
their daily routine when we ask people
here what they think of the Turkish
elections we were met with both optimism
and concern but for now it is unclear
what the outcome of the vote will mean
for syrians and this war rather's
country the karma
adlib Northern Syria